[Music]
we've known you for a while you and I
have talked many times yes on television
and off and well I don't think I'm not
putting you down in any way in any way
but you are a fantasy sci-fi geek is
that fair to say
yes I am a giant nerd your giant nerd
I'm curious in there in that realm of
sort of science fiction or fantasy have
you seen Hunger Games this huge
phenomenal success no I haven't seen it
because as a fat person I'm against
hunger care it sounds like a horror
movie huh I'm late old time Oh God
and then I found out it's about kids
murdering each other and as a father I'm
against child murder yeah so there's my
kids still young yeah so there's no way
you're gonna see this Mel I might see it
eventually in a hotel room somewhere by
myself right cuz on the committee I know
that sounds weird yeah I got a runner
hotel room Oh watch the hunger yeah
that's up here not here yeah your beard
did it come giant tightener like a big
star Wars fan or of the old Star Wars
cook no wait you wait wait you were
careful to say the old stalkers yeah I'm
gonna qualify it I hate the new Star
Wars
[Applause]
I'm still that guy I still get mad at
that stuff you know even though the
special editions came out almost 15
years ago and I'm mad at them and then I
got mad at the prequel or everything
everything since the original Star Wars
they come out that Lucas is done you're
mad about I looked at his betrayal it
was like my uncle tried to rape me or
something I know stay with me I sold I
didn't even sell my figures in the box I
gave him the Toys for Tots that's how
much like I didn't it was blood money
right I didn't want to see it again so
but so on that target and the new ones
come out on blu-ray right I'm there with
my wife and I just see the display she
doesn't see it she's looking at stuff
and and I see the display for the Star
Wars blu-rays of the special editions
and I just lose my mind I'm like yeah
very good I'm just freaking frigging
brain and I what kitc what did he maybe
articulate I get so mad like and to my
wife like goes what we're in Target
weirdo and and I go burn and I point at
the display and she turns around and
goes ah cuz she is just sick of hearing
the word star and wars together yes
because she's been with me since the
prequels you know the special edition
she's amazing from 16 years she's lived
through all this rage heard it and like
cuz Star Wars is my Vietnam like like
I'm that old guy like when young kids
talk about Star Wars you know the
Phantom Menace or whatever I'm like you
don't know Star Wars Star Wars 1977
George Lucas Guido didn't shoot first
mother
[Applause]
where
without you even trying you're becoming
Star Wars characters yeah that was very
Yoda right there don't like it I for
goss's inside me Oh like in more ways I
don't know how to stop this show that's
what my son my son is gonna have to hide
that from me he like it's not gonna be
pod or porno or anything like that he's
gonna come home one day and see my wife
and go hey mom I was over at Steve's I
saw the Phantom Menace it's not that bad
she's gonna go watch your goddamn mouth
your father'll leave